Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and
ahhh
just checking in on you. I can't yell at,
I am in New York City right now and
I'm, it's late. I forgot, you know,
today was Thursday and I had
to do the Po, the podcast,
so I apologize for it being
late. I, um, I dunno. I,
uh, I don't know. I wasn't thinking
the fuck do you want from me?
And all of a sudden I landed and I got a
bunch of tweets from people going to it
. I thought you were going to
check in on me. I was like, God,
I'm letting people down. I'm letting you
down. So here I am. I'm checking into,
so now you're gonna hear
it on Friday. Let's see.
Some lonely bastard on the west coast,
you know, still up or some lonely lay.
Um, anyways,
so I just got here to New York because
I'm doing Foxwoods this weekend.
And, um, since I left New York,
my neighborhood has become extremely gay.
And I don't mean it in a way that
all the gay people don't like.
When you say that neighborhood's gay,
like it stinks. I mean like literally gay.
I mean, men are attracted to men.
You know there's gay guys up and
down this trip and over each other.
And let me tell you thought.
Nobody's complaining honey. Right?
So here's the deal. When when
gaze move into your neighborhood,
there's three stereotypes
that everybody says. You know,
when gay people move into
the neighborhood, this is,
these are three things everybody says,
right? They say, number one, all right,
what are they saying? They
say the neighborhood's going
to become safer, right?
Number two, they say property values
that gotta to go up. And number three,
they say there's going to be all these
great new fucking restaurants and Holy
Shit, the cuisines going
to be fucking unbelievable.
Thank God the gay showed up.
Now this neighborhood
can fuck in, you know,
live up to its potential.
Well, they showed up.
Definitely got safer. Definitely
less shady. All right,
so check on the first one.
Stereotype number two.
Uh, the fuck did I say it was still
property value would go up? Yeah, it did.
But I miss New York. It
goes up everywhere, but you
know what? You know what?
It's election year. I don't want
to derail the podcast campaign.
I'll give you credit on
that one. Gay People,
it got safer and the property
values went up. And then lastly,
all this great cuisine was gonna
come here. And you know what?
It still hasn't shown up.
The food in my neighborhood absolutely
fucking sucks and I am so sick of it.
Okay. The goddammit,
I was told when these gay showed up
that the fucking food was going to get
better. And I think not only
is it not gotten better,
it's actually taken a nosedive.
I just went out and got a Burrito. Right.
What kind of asshole leaves Angeles and
then tries to get a Burrito in New York.
You're listening to them, this
asshole. All right. The Brito was fine.
Okay.
Yeah. Chicken Burrito,
whatever. It's funny, you know,
I looked at the menu was all this
fucking shit. I just looked at the,
the waiter, I felt like I
disappointed them. I was like,
can I just get some chips
and with guacamole salsa
and like just like a chicken
burrito. And I just saw
it in his eyes like, oh,
you want white people Mexican
food? And I was like, exactly.
I am as white as it gets and I will
have my Mexican food is white as I am,
please. Right. Um, and before, you know,
Mexican people write in and tell me that's
not real Mexican food. I understand.
I get it. All right, whatever.
This is what the fuck I wanted.
Here's my question.
How do you have all these gay people
walking up down the street and you can't
even make decent guacamole? How the
fuck does that happen? You know,
who do I blame in this
gay people slipping?
Is it because these are the millennial
gays and they're just Emoji in each
other? You know, I don't
know what's going on.
Um, I'm blaming the gates. I'm
blaming you guys on this one. Alright.
Whatever pressure used to put
on a fucking neighborhood,
you're not doing it anymore. Or what?
You decided not to do it in my
neighborhood. I was so fucking,
you know the anticipation.
Okay.
Once you guys to send in on this one
straight shady fucking neighborhood,
you know, and the rainbow flags
came out and all this shit.
When the fuck is the food truck
getting here? That's what I want.
Enough fucking pizza sucks.
The fucking guacamole sucks.
The Middle Eastern food sucks the
whole fuck it. They just sucks.
Everything is just like, it's, yeah.
How much I drank when
I'm in my neighborhood.
It's just so the fucking food
will tell. It's all like,
just get shit faced and didn't make
it fill up that hole in your stomach.
I don't know.
Maybe that's why I want all these gay
guys who are in such great shape around
here. They're cooking it on
a fuck. Nah, that pisses me off.
I just had a fucking God damn chicken
Burrito and Guacamole this late at night.
So at my age I, you know,
I'll probably have a heart attack around
eight 30 in the morning, you know?
At least it could have tasted good. Right?
Why is that fucking button
on it now? It's off. I want,
if you guys can hear this shit, f
whatever the fuck you going to do.
I don't know why the fuck I bring
my mixer and all that stuff.
God Damn and I'm in a grumpy mood
and I was in such a great mood.
There's nothing worse than when you're
starving and you go out and you order a
fucking meal, right
in a neighborhood that's now a gay
neighborhood and it sucks. I mean,
I'm talking literally like the two dudes
next to me at the end of their fucking
meal, right? They fucking like
kissed each other tenderly.
Can I at least get some
fucking decent guacamole?
How much care is it going to be around
here? It's only going at these burrito.
So I learned that stereotype
is a, is not true.
Just because they show up doesn't mean
the chefs are going to start fucking
throw in doubt that drop
in the fucking ball.
I'm not going to lie to you
when the two went to kiss, okay,
is as open minded as
I am. I have to admit,
I was wearing a baseball cap and I
tilted it down so I didn't see their lips
meet. You know, does that make me
a bad person? If you're judging me,
can I just tell you that
one of them look like that,
that fucking scrawny little
dude that J-lo married.
Just imagine that Guy
Kissing Lenny Kravitz.
You know, forgive me, I didn't
want to see it. You know,
maybe that makes me a
bad person, but whatever.
I am a work in progress
just like everybody else and
I will have a decent bowl
of fucking guacamole. You sons of
bitches. All right, let's plow ahead here.
So, um,
I flew out this morning and I actually
have this app on my phone where I can
listen to the control tower and I'm
just totally nerd now. You know,
every time he had the tower
talking about our plane of Sydney,
he's talking about us.
He just told us to go into this little
fucking taxiway or whatever, you know?
And, um, so I'm flying up front, right?
Cause at this point I, I spent 20
years in the back of the plane.
I'm not flying. I'm not fucking, I'm
not doing that anymore. I'm done.
I don't give a shit if I
lose money on the gigs,
I'm flying up front and for
all you guys, for 20 years,
I sat in the back of the plane looking
what goes on on the other side of that
curtain. What happens up
there? What is that like?
You know what happens up there? People,
spoiler alert. You know what happens?
They treat you like a human
being. I sweat. They do.
They treat you the way they treat
everybody in the commercials about their
airline. Right? Everybody's smiling,
having a good fucking time. You know,
you got a seat that's
actually comfortable. There's
nobody leaning on you.
Nobody breathing on you. You're hungry.
They bring you food, you're thirsty,
they bring you a drink. They
treat you like a fucking person.
It's posted in the back. Righteous
jamming in there, stuffing in there.
Right? So anyways,
two I board first because you know
I'm a fancy fucking guy, right?
So I fucking I board, right?
I can't say fancy guy.
Jim Norton says that fancy man. I'm a,
I don't know what I am the fucking
jerk off, right. So I get on,
I get on a plane, right?
And I'm this fucking lady behind me.
All right. The second she gets to a chair,
she just starts yelling on sir, sir,
stare. You know,
did she yelling at this foot that the
fucking male stewardess and he turns
around, he's like, Hey,
what's the problem?
And because there's something wrong
with my chair that on, is this broken?
Is it broken? Like freaking the
fuck out. And the guy's like, no.
The other person just, you know,
whoever was sat in this on the last
flight didn't bring in all the way to the
upright position. Oh. Because I
thought it was broken, you know?
And right there I immediately just
fucking hated this woman fucking,
and she had this,
the sniffles just kept sniffing and
shit didn't give a fuck about anybody.
And just, I swear to God,
this shit that I thought about her because
she sat up in the front of the plane,
I immediately judged and that she was
some rich company while I'm sitting up
there. Right.
Okay.
I don't know what she was thinking about
me was Baldwin head. Fuck. You know,
he used his miles to get up here.
Um,
okay.
Anyways, thought Jesus, I'm, I can,
I apologize early for the fucking
horrible fucking mood I'm in right now.
I was in such a great fucking mood,
you know, and I was actually, you know,
walking down the street here
in Manhattan and just laughing,
looking at these people, so excited
that I left this fucking place.
People in their 20s look,
okay? All right. In Manhattan,
they just got here. It's still
exciting. Okay. But see this, this,
this city beats the fuck out of you.
All right? I've always said, you know,
if you can do it, if you have a desire
to do it, at some point you life,
you gotta come here and
live here just to do it.
Cause it really is one of the most
amazing cities you're ever gonna, uh,
live in. But you know,
what else is amazing about after you
let you owe it to yourself, to Olivia,
and you also owe it to yourself
at some point to fucking leave.
I swear to God, Dude,
the amount of people that you see
walking down the street that looked like
shut-ins,
that finally just fucking came out
of the Cave of a God damn apartment.
Jesus Christ. I fucking walked into my
building and this lady standing there,
she looks like one of the
patients on shutter island.
Fucking dark circles under her eyes.
Her hat yanked down like one of those
people that's like ageless. It's like,
are you 70 or 26 I don't
even know what you just,
your skin is gray, right? And she's with
this older dude kind of look like me.
To be honest with you, I'm
a little chunkier, you know,
probably a lot more jollier. He's
probably not pitching about the Guacamole,
right? And I'm fucking like, hey,
excuse me. As I go, hey, how are you?
Excuse me. As I got to walk by,
and she does like this weird like
[inaudible] to get out of the fucking way.
Like, oh my God, another human
big. And then as I go to walk away,
she starts singing in this
beautiful voice as she walked up.
She is an amazing,
beautiful fucking voice.
Okay.
I said, so what? What happened
to you? Jesus fucking Christ.
What's like the way she looked and then
the sound that came out of it was like
haunting. Then I felt like I was
in one of those horror movies.
You know that now I'm in and now I
can't get out. You know what I mean?
She's actually a vampire is gonna
come by later to feed, you know?
Then I become her boyfriend forever
cause we're both vampires until she gets
sick of me and finds up fucking, I
don't know, a younger version of me.
That doesn't happen. Right.
The fucking red headed male
is never a love interest.
That doesn't happen in movies, you know?
Do you hear us bitching about
it or we boycott in anything?
I don't think so. We just trudge on
trying to stay out of the sun.
That's what it feel like when it
come to New York. Everybody here,
did she just go, can you get some
sun in your fucking face? Something?
What's that vitamin you get when the,
when the sun shines on you? It's,
it was fuck it. Things that everybody
just says in a bar. Oh yeah, vitamin D,
Sun's gone for your vitamin
E, you know, not too much,
but you know it's good for you. You know
what they say? You know what they say?
It raises your levels of, Oh, is that
what they say? Say what they say.
They're a guy with his fucking name
on his shirt. What do you do? Well,
what do you for you fucking on
clog during the course of the day.
What are you talking medical here for me?
For me or to me? Why are you doing it?
All right. You fucking plumber.
I say that with extreme prejudice.
You know, that's the one trade.
I don't respect the plumbing. You know,
cause I go to home depot and I swear
to God, I can almost figure it out.
Electrical. That's like wizardry. You're
a fucking wizard, right? Plumbing.
[inaudible] I mean he just opened the
door so everything's right there in the
sink. You know, once it goes in
the wall, then I give it to you.
You know what I mean? Then
you're a closer. All right?
But if you just find a way to
hit it with a wrench, he on Dick,
shut off the main fucking
water and yeah. Yeah.
Fucking he, I don't know. Until you're
young, screw it. Right. If you can,
you can fucking open and close.
Or You could take the lid off a jar if
you can remember what the thing is that's
on top of a jar. Right? You're smart
enough to be a fucking plumber.
I just don't respect that trait.
You know? Look, they they,
they really are. They're like welders
or this shit electricians or the shit.
People get fabricate stuff.
People who build hot rods, those,
that's the upper echelon. Those
are the one they have like the,
I work with my hand awards, my hands,
I should say. They're not jerking off.
I worked with my hands when
they have those awards. Right.
They've got to have those at some
point. The welders, right, or some shit,
whatever the fuck it is. You know?
Those are the people that bring
home the fucking hardware.
Nobody gives it to a plumber. Plumber.
Yeah. Once you go on clog something,
what trade did you really
want to be good at? Huh?
It's funny right now,
there's a plumber out there that's
actually getting upset by this
and someone will present it on another
website is if I was fucking serious.
Hang on, I'm trying to get
through my fucking password here.
Plumber Jesus Christ. I mean,
the whole fucking state.
It doesn't even sound perspectival
does it? Um, oh my God, dude.
The other night I fucking met law head
for a drink. Okay. I was just like,
dude, I am trying not to booze, but
I, I gotta I gotta have a couple,
two or three, right? So he
goes, all right. He goes,
you know, I'm doing a spot.
I'll meet you over at this bar.
So we go to the bar and sit in there
with shooting the shit with have a great
time. And uh, this the plumber
thing, this is what reminded me.
So this big guy comes in. By
big, I mean fat, all right?
Big Mother and hips to puts it
on like Oprah thighs and ass.
And then he also puts it on like a dude
and he puts it on like a chick and a
dude. This was just a fat man
and you know, he, he was obese,
but he wasn't even biggest loser
fat. He just was, he was just tall.
He was a mountain of a fucking man.
So he sits down at the bar store
just off the off of the, you
know, La head's right shoulder.
It's a really not a well lit bar.
And I'm just sitting there and I'm looking
and he's got this weird design
on his pants and I'm just like,
what the fuck is that? That's weird.
Is that a new style at genius on those
big dazzled jeans that everybody was
wearing like 10 15 years ago?
It looked like he had a horseshoe
on, on your pockets. You know,
the big thing was to have
the stitching like that.
The blue jeans were blue and then
you had the, it was all white.
I never bought those. I'm so
fucking glad I never bought those.
There's not one picture of me in those.
There's already pictures of me and Z.
Cavariccis okay. I don't need
it. I don't need to, you know,
jump on that trend
either, you know? So, um,
I'm sitting there going, what is
that design? It looked like, like,
like almost like he ordered custom pants
and they just didn't put this design
right and I looked a little closer,
my eyes adjusted and I realized
it was his hairy ass crack.
I couldn't fucking believe
it. This guy sat down,
he was so big, dude, I am telling you
there was the top of his ass crack.
He was so fat. It was like twice
the size of my whole ass crack.
That's why I didn't take it was
that, and it was fucking Harry,
I apologize for putting this image in you,
but it was hairy so it looked
like it was a design and it,
I just can't fucking in Lawhead what was
caught my eyes when I realized what I
was looking at and he was
like, dude, what the fuck?
And when I told him
what had just happened,
I don't think I've ever
made law laugh like that.
He was fucking howling
in this bar to the point.
I think even the guy looked
over at us. Oh my God.
Well I kept saying that. I said that
you could measure I was going to do it.
How can that be? How could
they be more ass crack
like this weird like when you lose weight
you like if you become a fat fuck you
have a giant, so you have this,
I never thought about this.
You have this giant fucking ass
crack. So when you lose the weight,
like the crack goes away too,
right. That doesn't seem,
money doesn't make sense to me.
Cause it seems like it's a hole in
your body kind of. You know, I don't,
I don't know where I was trying
to figure it out and I was,
I was riffing about this dog discussing
this was a the fuck did I say?
I was saying,
you remember that home run Mark McGuire
hitting the kingdom off to Randy
Johnson, I would say.
And you could measure that home run with
the amount of ass crack this guy had
coming out of the top of his
pants. And that was just his,
that was just as plumber
crack. Oh, Jesus Christ.
What a fucking image they'd gone air
already ate before I did this. Huh? Um,
all right, let's, uh, I, Oh God,
I wish I had video of my, you know,
they always do those reaction
videos that just fucking see,
like you must have done that
before, right. You know,
when you look and say, Oh,
what is that? And then you realize
you don't know. I don't know,
pretty much gross things
in your head. Oh God,
I've got another disgusting story.
I should I do it at this point.
If he get grossed out easily. Um,
you know, you should have tapped out
by now. You want another gross one?
You know, I gotta read the advertising.
I promise. I'll tell you I,
this one is really,
really fucking gross. Um,
all right, here we go. You know,
if I'm going to tell you that I'm going
to tell you that one and they'll tell
you another one of like the,
basically the two grossest things
that ever happened to me on off.
There's another one, Jason, what's funny,
they're all like fucking 15
years apart. Like every 15 years.
Like just something fucking
gross happens to Z. Amy,
if you lucky as a human
being. All right, here we go.
Let's get the reeds going here. All right.
Oh Shit. Here we go. Club Debby club,
Gabby folk for Kim clip. Debbie.
Um, if you're anything like me,
then you know exactly what you
like and how you like it. Well,
don't fucking talk shit for
me. If you're anything like me,
you question everything you do. And then
the next day, like, why did I say that?
All right. If you're anything like
the people that they think that I am,
you know what you like
and how you like it,
except when you're in the wine
aisle, tannins and to Terry,
our hours mean nothing to you.
I know what the fuck those,
and those are types of wine, I guess.
Unless you happen to be a fancy pants,
professional sommelier, you know,
there's no reason to shit on people
in wine just because you know,
they know something that you
don't, right. It's not wizardry.
They may can booze that just into
it. You know what I mean? It's like,
listen to somebody who's into star
wars. Really talk about star wars.
That's like, yeah, I saw it
once. What are you talking about?
I don't understand what you're
in. They can like, you know,
they know the rock that
the fucking little,
what are those little chihuahuas?
I still remember that my brother collected
the action figures. Such a jealous,
right? Those little fucking secret
society looking fuckers. Right?
And the thing getting sacrifice a
virgin. Um, what bloods under that rope.
All right. Club Debbie, please include
all the falling shit and you read.
All right, well with club
Debbie full for GM. Come on.
Can't be Trump a, the guessing
game is over club Debbie.
But Daddy still loves me. It's the
world's most personalized wine club.
And your are sent directly to your door.
Not only does club wea come to my ranch,
I'll make you some burgers
sent or y send you wine.
They send you wine that
you'll love drinking. Uh,
that's because club Debbie club. Gabby,
nothing happened on my watch except
when it did a easy six questions.
Quiz figures out your pallets.
So I gotta stop doing the club w
shit cause I can't read the fucking,
that's because club W's easy.
Six question quiz figures out your pallet
so that every bottle you receive is
perfectly tailored to
your tastes club. Debbie
is leading the grape to
glass wine revolution.
Okay.
Uh,
they worked directly with the vineyard
to cut out the middleman which saves you
money club. Debbie Medan who was a
world war two pilot, I skipped the war.
Even others even offers a no risk
guarantee that you're going to love.
They'll send you or the love what you
send your the or you get your money back.
G and why don't we just
fucking improvisers thing
cause I can't read right now.
Uh,
and right now club Debbie is offering my
listeners 50% off your first order when
you go to club debbie.com/burr wine
should be fun. Not Pretentious.
Start learning. Well why don't
you fucking escalate yourself?
Why are you going to
bring the wine world down?
Yeah,
listen this smarter than up. We
are, you know the fuck you want.
Start learning as you drink it.
Club. debbie.com/burger ice drink.
I don't drink anymore. I
speak Spanish. You'll leave.
Get 50% off your first order.
That's club Debbie at.com/burger has
anybody seen Dick Cheney? Alright.
Legal Zoom. To run a successful business,
you need to make the most of your
time and your money. Good News.
Legal Zoom can help you save both
during national small business month.
Legal Zoom is the smart way to start
your business. For some reason,
when I read like this, I
don't fuck it up right now.
When you incorporate or form an LLC,
you can also save money on some
of the basic shit I fucked up.
You can also save money on some of
the basics to get up and running
like@threemonthtrialofquickbooksonlineaccountingsoftwareandadomainnameforayearthroughweb.com
both at no charge after
your business is set up,
legal zoom can help you with a lot more
reviewing contracts and dealing with
the day to day legal hurdles takes time
away from growing your business.
That's why that's what legal
zoom business legal plan is for.
You get legal advice for your business
from independent attorneys licensed in
for 48 states legally,
and I just want to throw an illegal in
there and somebody fucking legal. Uh,
you also get access to NDAs,
lease agreements and more.
The best part is you won't
get charged by the hour.
Since legalzoom isn't a law firm.
Instead you pay a low monthly fee,
save time and money.
Start starting and running your
business during national small business
month@legalzoom.com today.
Don't forget to enter Burr and
the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com and also if you'd
like to contribute to this podcast,
but you don't want to give me any
money next time you go to Amazon,
swing by Bill bird.com,
click on the podcast page and all
you do is click the link to Amazon.
It takes you right to Amazon, doesn't
cost you an extra dime, and they just,
I get credit for driving traffic to
their site. You will go in there anyways,
but don't tell them all right. And I'll
then I dedicate the dedicated, I donate,
you know, a percentage of what
you give me 10%, you know, to uh,
to the fucking, uh, oh Jesus.
What the fuck's that call?
I'll go and I always tell
you the charities to cause,
so then you guys can tell me that
they're scams later. Saint Jude.
Nobody's gotten any dirt on these
fucking guys. Alright. Alright.
I'm not gonna tell you all the gross
stories. I'll tell. I'll tell you.
I'll tell you one quick
one. All right. Um,
I was living, I had roommates, I
was living in this place and uh,
I got up early and I went
into the bathroom and take
a shower and I looked down
and what looked to be a brown wash cloth,
you know, that was all twisted up. Uh,
the bottom of the shower. I
think, you know, what's his going,
I reached down to pick it
up and if somebody had,
one of my roommates
had shit in the shower,
I never got over that.
I woke them all up. They
were all awoken by who?
Shit in the shower.
And they were laughing because I'd have
think laughing because it was hilarious.
And then also I started laughing
because it'd be literation later. I did,
but like,
I literally could not eat with that hand
for like fucking a month and thinking
now I actually, I don't remember
what she had. It was, I mean,
it's fucking disgusting. It's the
processing. That's the study. It's funny.
Is it, do you know what, if you laugh at
that right now, you're a sick fuck. Um,
and who am I if I told you
about it? Right? So anyways,
I was on the plane and, um,
I started watch this space
movie and um, you know,
it's just another one of those space
movies where it's just like, you know,
everybody dies or people leave.
There's always just like the
one person left out in space,
how are they going to survive?
And I started to watch it.
It's like I already saw this
fucking movie two years ago.
Sandra Bullock did this
movie, right? She could go,
I left alone when Richard Gere fucking
floated off into sweat. I would,
his fucking guy's name is the guy with
the motorcycles, right. Married the lady,
finally guy from oceans 11th one of
those guys. He has so much charisma.
All he has to do is just say
the fucking line. You know,
he doesn't have to throw in its dirty
mustard on it. That guy, George Clooney,
George Clooney, he just says the
fucking line and yet believe him.
Right? Fucking guys fearless.
You'd see him in that movie.
He didn't give a fuck. Yeah, I'm
just going to float out into space.
He's still cracking jokes and shit. Just
going to go over here and suffocate.
Take it easy sandy. Right. That's
it man. That's all man goes out.
I bet once she floated out of her
fucking ear shot, he started crying.
Woo.
I just sit there fucking
floating around. Um,
you gotta love Scifi. You know
I gotta love cy Fi. You know,
I said I hate watching real shit about
space cause all they do is just tell you
how infinite it is and how insignificant
we are. It's like I get it. I got it.
Do you have anything else?
Have you filed one fucking living
thing out there. You have it.
So there's really nothing to report
other than it's so fucking immense and we
still don't have the technology
to meet anybody. That's why you,
if you really want to see something about
space, you got to watch his psi movie,
you know, say what you want a
bottom at least a fine shit.
You know there's car chases and
people, you know, hot chick aliens,
right? Space bars and stuff like that.
You plucking put on of Bravo shows with
that black guy there who fucking knows
everything. What's his name? He's like,
he's like the guy from the matrix.
Laurence Fishburne, except for
just Fishburne. Fishburn whatever.
He's like that guy, except he's
real. The Lawrence is real.
I'm talking about his character.
I fucking watched that guy.
I've watched that guy like
three times and I, I just was,
he had me believing that we came from
the trees. I'm like, this guy is. Yeah,
we, and I was like, I thought
we came from the ocean of mud.
I was going with that and this guy's
like, no, we're from the trees.
We got the same fucking,
I don't know what he said,
but I mean there was nothing between my
ears that could argue with anything that
he said. You just have
to fucking listen to it.
I remember just sitting there
watching the guy just going like,
this has gotta be what it's
like when you join a cult.
Like how dumb I feel right now.
That's what you have to do.
Like I was reading this, this
fucking thing. Who's kidding who?
I was browsing it. I don't
really read anything.
We saw this picture and I just put words
to it in my brain and now I'm telling
it to you. There's some
fucking guy I know.
He had like 80 wives, one of those
fucking Weirdos out in fucking Utah.
You know what I mean? I, I'll
either that or he's just like,
how can rappers don't
talk about those guys?
They're always talking about fucking
pimps. How can a guy, that's key.
The guy's got 80 fucking women.
They all know about each other and they're
all smiling in the fucking picture.
Huh?
I want to see somebody else pull that
off and not live in the middle of fucking
Utah. I don't know what
the fuck it is about Utah,
but you could talk a woman
into anything out there.
You're the a one for me. Hi. Yeah,
you are no 79 other bitches. Okay,
but go make me some butter bitch. Um,
this guy's in prison and he's
still running that. This harem.
Okay.
They don't know any better.
You know when you're walking around with
a little house in the prairie clothes,
I mean, you can fucking tell
people anything. That's the key.
You know what I mean? They feel
like if you want to start a cult,
it's very difficult to start
it with people that have
gone to a department store
and bought their clothes,
you know? But if you,
if there's a group of people that are
standing there and clothes that they made
themselves, you get, that's where
you start. You know what I mean?
It's like when you've got
a shit team, all right?
And you got the number one
draft, pick the t, the guy,
the person you're going to
build your fucking team around.
That franchise player.
When it comes to cult,
those still the franchise tag is on all
those people with those little house in
the prairie clothes, those
Quaker clothes, right? The QC.
Okay.
You know, you ever think about start? I'd
started cult. I would do it, you know,
I would definitely start it
fucking called, but then I,
after a while I wouldn't want to do
the work and I would just, I'd Sorta,
I'd start like a, what do you call that?
When you fucking don't want to do
your job and you have other people do
delegating. I'd start delegating all
the fucking things and then granted,
one point some people
going to be like, whoa,
hey shea was [inaudible] how
come he's not doing anything?
I don't remember reading anything
about Jesus being being lazy.
Let he just sits around
and fucks everybody.
Yeah,
I'm going to check it as man shit.
Maybe I'm Jesus. Right?
And then he takes over.
Then all of a sudden they all
show up one day. You know,
is there anything scarier than angry,
stupid people standing in close
that they made themselves?
Just picture what that would look like.
You know the amount of Mano Browse
staring back at you and you just have to
relinquish your power and just at some
point ease your way out the back door and
let them know that you're
not the son of God.
There's a fucking afternoon
for you, Huh? Jesus Christ.
How many dead bolts would you
have on your bedroom door?
I'm speaking of which, by the way,
I got all the fucking interior
door locks fixed on my house.
They all have fucking skeleton keys.
And then I found this fucking person on
the Internet on the interweb as Richard
Rollins says, from fast and
loud. Uh, another great show. Um,
I got some of that's gonna
line it up with the door jam.
You know the little fucking latch thing,
Dan. And I'm going to be good to go.
It's going to be, fuck. I can't
wait. Very excited about that.
And speaking of great shows, I'm
finally caught up with better call Saul.
I feel like such a, not only a
bad fan considering, you know,
Vince hooked me up to be in, I'll
have a small part in breaking bad.
I should've been watching right along.
But what happened was those of you
who listened to the podcast last year,
I fucking was taping the thing.
For some reason I didn't get episode
three and then I suck computers and the
Internet. I couldn't figure out
where else I could watch it.
So I've been stuck on episode two.
So finally they came on Netflix right
before season two started and I just binge
watched the entire first season
and it was fucking unbelievable.
Whose fucking amazing
starts. It just, it's,
I don't want to ruin anything for you,
but I gotta tell you something like a,
the level of acting that everybody's
doing, but like Bob old Kirk man,
you know, it's very rare that someone
is, is as great a comic as he is,
is equally as great a
fucking actor. He was,
I want you guys to watch it
just cause you got to see,
he has this blow out fight. I can't
ruin this for you with a relative.
Any now you just say
mean shit to each other.
His brother says something to him.
I've been thinking about that line
for like the last five fucking days.
It was just, I dunno,
it's one of those lines.
Okay.
That in real life usually gets set around
the holidays after you've been sitting
on something for 20 fucking
years, and when it comes out,
it's needle off the fucking record and
the relationship is over. It's just like,
yeah, dude, I'll see you when you're
on your deathbed or I'm on my deathbed,
or maybe never again. I mean, it's,
it's a fucking rap. It's over.
Um, oh man. The writing was just,
it was just fucking outstanding and I'm
can't say enough good things about it
and I am totally caught up and, uh,
I can't wait for next week's
fucking episode. There you go.
There's my little plug there for
better call Saul. Um, and with that,
that's it for this, uh, checking
in on your podcast. Once again,
I apologize for a few, you know,
for not doing the podcast
on t t on timely fashion,
a timely fashion over the fuck you said.
I realized that I brought up that app.
Sorry about the shit in the shower
story. The ass crack one was funny.
I don't give a fuck
who you are by the way.
That app is three 99 that I,
if you want to listen to the
towers anywhere where you're at,
it's called live t c. Dot. Net app.
Just do that ATC air traffic control. Um,
and it's really cool.
Like I just thought you could listen
to the towers and near you but you can
actually, um,
I was at lax today and
I was listening to uh,
Logan Airport in Boston and
it's really cool cause you, you,
you're basically like, I'll click on
California. They got Burbank, Cambra,
Rio Concorde, any place in El
Monte, any place you want to go to.
And when you click on it
as I'm doing right now,
okay, this one has ground and
tower and then you click on that.
Um, and then there's,
what's really cool is they have
like a diagram of the airport.
So like you can actually, you know, I
like to listen to it when, whatever,
whatever airport I'm at, as
we're taxing out to the, um,
to whatever the fucking runway,
Jesus Christ bells, you know,
you'd think you'd know that,
um, go out to the runway.
I just like listening to it and it's
fucking coolest shit. And I'm, you know,
watching the, um,
Jason Spill all the taxiways going by,
sorry, I'm trying to multitask here.
Answering a text message on, I apologize.
Let me just put the fucking phone,
don't see that, see that, pick it up.
And all of a sudden I thumb just
starts clicking on other stuff.
I'm gonna Start fucking looking at Twitter
and when I'm trying to do a podcast
here anyway, she get the whole layout
of the airport and as you go on down,
he could tell what taxiway
you're on. And then, uh,
hey, last way, right? So Charlie,
there you go. See that? You
just listened to that shit.
So that guy just obviously was cleared
to land and that was the runway.
And he said his tail number, that's it.
So I just listened to that shit because a,
that's one of the hard things when
you first get a pilot's license,
when you get up there, it all
just sounds like, hey, I want to
join a damn way. I'm gonna [inaudible]
they don't even have southern accents,
but that's what the fuck
it sounds like to me. Um,
you know what's funny is when
this shit happens, when I, uh,
when I'm just like walking around, like
I'll accidentally set a pocket dialing,
I'll hit this fucking app.
And uh, if you're in the mob,
do not get this fucking app because
they'll think it's a bunch of fucking feds
in a, in a van down the street.
You know,
if you fucking sitting there in a mob
meeting and all of a sudden you got this
fucking thing going and you're talking
about some bullshit and out of nowhere
this thing comes on. Come on. Just
do it one time. One more time for me.
Come on. This is Lex. Oh,
it's a quiet night out there.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
All of a sudden you just hear some
fucking guys voice in there talking some
official
seven 51 cross from way too
far left. [inaudible] ground.
Hey, what a fuck out there.
Fucking next. You know that the,
I can get tongue through your
throat. Um, all right, sorry.
That was a long way to go. Why, where
to go? Who uses a prop and a podcast?
All freckles does. Hey, go
fuck yourselves. You can't.
So I hope you have a great weekend
and a, his little music from Andrew,
Sam Willis,
a little throwback podcast from
a Monday or Thursday gone by
[inaudible] [inaudible]
you know, a few weeks ago
somebody was asking me, you know,
they wanted to break up with
somebody and I was saying, listen,
you gotta listen. You know,
the person who has it down how to do
the breakup was minivan men podcast,
own celebrity star Al Madrigal.
But if you don't have
time to email Al Madrigal
just listened to ll cool j a big old, but
I don't know why. I never really
listened to him when I was growing up.
You know, Mama said knock you out.
Did she? Is that what she said?
Ll Cool J I don't care. You know,
I just wasn't into witness deodorant
in his armpits when he was jamming with
those white guys. I just, I
never got into it. But lately,
lately, I dunno. I don't know
what happened. I G's just come
onto my youtube shit. I
don't know what it is,
but I was listening to some
of his stuff. Oh, I know why.
Yesterday I was trying to remember like,
what was that song he used to have that
I'm the type of guy and you're the type
of guy you put that,
what the fuck was that?
And then I listened to it and I kind of
liked it, but I hated that. Oh, we, oh,
part of it really
annoyed me. I'm like, oh,
that's why I never downloaded this shit.
But then on the side they
had a ll cool j big old,
but you know, I played drums at
Michael. Let me hear what this tracks.
I was like, can I put it on?
And he basically teaches you how to break
up with a girl and that song or that
rap or that, uh, that rhyme, whatever,
however you supposed to say it.
He breaks it down and just
in like fucking 11 seconds,
he sits his girls down.
He's basically hanging out and like some
sunglass hut or some shit and some girl
comes in with an insane ass and
he does whatever he guy does.
He stares out and he thinks, I
want to fuck that. But Oh shit.
I have a girlfriend. So what does
he do? Does he sneak around on her?
No, he goes home and he sits
her down. He says, listen,
I met this girl named Tina.
Okay. Teen has got a big old,
but I know that I said I'd be true.
I'm really whiten this up.
But Tina got a big old butt,
so I'm leaving you. It's, I mean,
that's just fucking air tight.
He can't fuck with that. He was 100%
I don't know. She could get mad.
I think that's that.
I think women's show expect guys to be
lying weasely pieces of shit that if you
actually hit them with
that level of honesty,
I think they would just be stunned.
Just like the chicken, the video.
Like I didn't think that
that was bad acting.
I think that they would absolutely be
stunned if you just came home and said,
listen, I met this girl.
I know that I said I'd be faithful to
you, but she's better looking than you.
So I'm up with you.
Well, what is the combat? There's nothing.
There'll be like if your girl came home
and said, listen, I know we're together,
but this guy, you know,
I met him at the mall,
his Dick is twice the size of
yours and he's got a better car.
So it's kind of a no brainer. Amati
what are you going to do?
What are you going to do with your little
dick and your fucking Domino's pizza?
It's over. You just gotta fucking be
like, you know, you only go around once.
So, uh, yeah, I, I, I get it.
So anyway, so if you don't
have time to email Al Madrigal,
which you should, which you should, uh,
just listen to a ll cool j big old bud.
You got to see his face. He
goes, so I'm leaving you. It's,
it's, I don't, can't explain it.
It's way meaner than it has to be.
That's what it makes it funny.
Cause there's a way to read that where
you're kind of letting them down easily,
you know, but he didn't,
he just did it like, yeah,
this is how it works. So they
would go look at that on a holiday.
Um, anyways, this is the Monday
morning podcast. It is the end of May.
Everybody. All right,
how many days are in May?
30 days had September
sodas, April and November.
All the rest have a bunch of
other dates except for statuary.
Go Fuck yourself with your song. Um,
she got 30 31 fuck, what is it?
April has 30. June has 30
maze. 31 well, what do I got?
The little thing I can click
right here. I'll have a computer.
I don't need to think right. It has.
Why is it in September?
Oh, for Christ sake,
do I have to click another
button? It has 31 days.
All right,
so you had till have you guys have until
Thursday midnight to make something of
May, 2012 all right. Are you
on a fucking relationship?
You don't want to be in? Do you
want to be in this relationship?
You don't want to be in in June?
Why don't you celebrate the end of
May by getting out of your fucking
relationship and sitting down
and basically just go
with the ll cool j vibe,
hold her hand and just go straight
honesty and then what she going to do?
Well, what is he going to do if
they're going to flip the fuck out,
but the die has been cast
to ship his set sail.
The ball is already rolling. The
Sun is setting, the rain is fallen.
Whatever the fuck you want to call it,
it's out there. Just put it out there.
Let them scream and yell and in
your head, as much as he sucks,
you're going to be like,
okay, I did it. I did it.
Now I've just got to sit here
and get yelled at and uh,
how long did somebody really yell
before they lose their voice? An hour.
90 minutes and an hour and a half.
I'm going to be in the car listening to
ll cool j driving away from that thing I
didn't want to be in. All right. And
I know I talk about this shit a lot,
but I think a lot of people
are in situations like this.
They don't know how to sit somebody
down. It just say, so I'm leaving you.
You know, if I was ll cool
J and I stop, you know,
selling tickets and all that type of shit,
that would be a side
business that I would have.
I would take that little fucking rhyme
that he had and I would custom do it for
everybody in their life and just make
people who just write you all right,
I need to charge it. You charge him a
hundred bucks and he would write you a,
you know, four bars.
It all rhymes and you just get out exactly
what you're saying. You know,
just be like you eat with your mouth
open. I know I said that I'd be true,
but you eat with your mouth open
so I'm leaving. You just get right.
You just get right down to
it. Your mom is a fucking con.
I know I said that I be true,
but she's fucking always coming over
here and some the runs with coffee.
You know I ain't got the, you
got the idea right? Jesus Christ.
What do I have to be yellow?
[inaudible]
let's get back into this mark from a
doesn't a furious. Yeah, I guess so.
All right.
Hi. What's up Ron? Standing here
with the guys from a dozen crs.
How do you guys think you set went to
that? Oh, I think it went really well,
man. I mean try that. Been the
hottest day so far in the whole tour.
But you know, we're Texas boys. Where
do you see the heats? I'll get up there.
Let's do our thing, man. So
you guys are like brand new.
You guys have won like a contest or
something to get on this? Yeah, I mean we,
we want a contest to be on the show. I
mean to be on the tour, but you know,
we've been a band for about two years now,
but touring on her own and doing
her own thing and you know,
this was pretty much just a
blessing, you know, you know,
a big step forward for us.
Definitely a blessing. How well
this is what I'm trying to get these guys
to say some fucked up like what you do
on tour and these guys, these
guys are covered in tattoos.
They all look like Mick Mars.
Yeah, Motley crew and they just,
I like the nicest guy ever. Needs to
blessing everything. Blessing to be here.
I noticed that in the
last days. God willing,
we'll go on to the next tour and why not?
I'll try to angle it towards some sort
of smut and they just keep going back to
the church.
Remember that when we did the [inaudible]
thing and there they're eating
vegetarian meals, backstage tofu or
drinking little green tea. It's like,
what's your, all you're going out
it up. They watch behind the music.
They saw that happens. Meanwhile
you're listened to behind them.
A contrast soundtrack to hell is play.
I know there's something going on in the
background that just listen to music.
How well or how well do people know
you're here? Um, so far it's been great.
I mean, we've done two signings and
they've been packed in tons of kids.
See what's the biggest asshole pride
you guys have been in front of him?
Just been like, fuck you. You're
the open advanced none yet man.
They've all been really cool.
I think they came out not expecting like
us to do what we actually do. You know,
everybody thought we were going to be
some MTV show man and stuff like that,
but it turns out, you know,
everybody's like, man,
you guys blew us away
and it's really cool.
Like lots of Ford from the fans and shit.
So I mean we're like, oh, that's cool.
All right. You have the
other drama, right? Yes sir.
Have you ever like went to throw the drum
sticks in the crowd and some dude was
pissing you off so you can
Kinda, rather than tossed it,
just fucking throw it at him. Not
really that. It's just not somebody.
If you could put an eye out,
we wouldn't do things like that.
Make sure it's a rubber tip and I guess
we have special styrofoam drum sticks
that we throw out. So it was not to
injure any of our loving fans. Wow.
They were not biting. Even these
hardcore fans have become PC.
It gets even better.
I at it as far as like
hello. Good to see you again.
So many people talk really cold some off
first and so you know who gets the most
[inaudible]. None of us were all,
we're all a, we're all thinking, man.
Ah, we're in loving
relationships with lovely women.
It's just, it's the most
anti rock and roll. Wow.
Can Roll band okay.
Yeah, we're all good. We're all good.
This is really, you guys are the tattoos.
I'm figuring is this going to be maniac
going back to, and guys all committed.
Oh, we're all committed.
Anybody got a baby on the way?
You want to announce a daughter
already? The rest of the,
what's her name up in the Madison
Madison ass. And that's a beautiful
hi. And then the names of
their kids on and Matt as safe.
Madison destined for a
pole though in Madison.
You know Zach named his son [inaudible]
Hendricks handed Jimmy Hendrix.
[inaudible] fucking animal is still
the real deal. It's an animal.
But these newer bands, you know
Billy just trifle beautiful.
I got, I got him to do
a PSA though in the end.
What's her name? Madison. Madison.
And that's a beautiful name. Hey,
we're doing a skin cancer awareness
thing here on now. Open Anthea.
So if you guys could just say
something to make, you know,
the kids that were about
skin cancer, just wing it.
Anything throw a couple of fucks in
there so the kids are listen to it.
You know, I do that. We are
out in the sun all day long,
every day and we put on sunblock probably
like my times throughout the day. Man.
You know, you got to take care of
yourself. You got take care of,
just start over again. Just throw a
couple of bucks in them. Seriously? Yeah.
Yeah. That's crazy. No, again.
All right. Just say, you know,
seeing cancer awareness. I man,
we're fucking pot bags and we put
on a lot of sunblock. Fuck. Ah,
yeah. We're out in the
fucking sun all day long, man.
It's just fucking beat down
on you and you know, dude,
you gotta fucking take care of
me dude. You gonna wear stumble.
I gonna wear it over and
over again. Especially.
You want to keep attaching fresh
shoes. You need to tighten it up.
Tighten it up real quick. Where
are your fucking sunblock? Bitches.
Bye guys.
All right, listen Ron [inaudible] idea.
I can do pieces thought I've eaten with
each band cause I had no idea where they
were.
So with each band I just made whatever
the PSA was more ridiculous and just
always had them like throat. Just throw
a couple of fucks in there. Kids. Yeah,
the kid, you know, it's crazy. Something
a little rock and roll attitude.
I gotta say going into
that, I was like, ah,
audio from a band called a
dozen furious. Who Cares?
That was really interesting. And
in a lot of levels. Oh, they just,
they job bill bar. So what ordered me?
You ever have an orgy? Ah, you know,
more just like one on one connection
with somebody you know, really scary.
Monogamous on our relationships.
They're just not living their
rock and roll lifestyle anymore.
We know the whole arms. Oh,
I understand. I understand.
They got all the luck in the park.
You got the piercings that tattoos
and mixed messages. Yes. All right.
What about this Ben? Shadows
fall. Yeah, same shit.
I just would ask them questions and a
would go nowhere and then I just had them
do a PSA. Yeah. Well we got to
listen until we get to the PSA.
It's Brian from shadows.
Well, no, it's up. Stillbirth opening
anything show. I'm talking to Brian.
Fare from shadows fall. Grits.
That man has to feel about it. Oh,
that's what ask man. The whole
asbestos is incredible, man. You know,
sharing a stage with maiden and Sabbath
doesn't get any better than that.
It's how to help you sing
like that for so long.
And I yelled at my dad like that
for about 20 minutes of my time.
I couldn't talk much. I'm used to it for
yelling at my girlfriend that much you,
I was like, you know, builds it up. You've
got to build the strength, you know,
you know what? I'm going to do that
drop right now. You know what's good?
You'd glad you brought that up.
We had a opening at these doing like
a thing for like domestic violence
awareness. Yes.
Somebody kicked the shit out of that
girlfriend and like Newark or something.
So yeah. So just, just, just add,
lift some sort of dropped
and not do domestic violence,
see a girlfriend or
whatever, not, and you know,
it's kind of way it costs a couple of
amp moms in that just because I listened
as a retarded, but just try to
keep the good message. So just,
it was five shells fall and said,
hey, I just don't, you know,
oh, is such a great gag. Rockville.
You're gonna have to come back and
Redo this, uh, this new gag, right?
This is your thing.
Just say this five shouts ball and
so yeah, I just don't see it up.
Your girlfriend, you know, fucking
don't beat up your girlfriend again.
Let's not this bribe shadows fall, man.
You've got to stop punching your
girlfriend out there and say shit for the
bedroom. You know that's where it's at.
But don't take it to the streets. Okay.
Do it again. Just roll like one
fucking, then somebody got their idiots.
I was bribed. Shadow squad. Just say
stop hitting your fucking girlfriend.
You Idiots. All right. Save to violence
for the bedroom. My cool iron man.
So La, what do you guys go
from here? Um, after this, uh,
where the hell are we
tomorrow. Two days here.
Then we've got know I
don't even know where we go
us and they bring me where I gotta
be. It's hilarious. What do you,
what'd you think about playing out
here in the yard? The parking lot.
Do you think it was gonna be one, like
a seated area? Cause I know I did.
I was kind of like, oh actually we're
on the main stage so you know that's it.
I like the parking lot by it actually
better cause there's no seats in the way
case you can go crazy.
That's thing you know we're gonna
be playing with where their seats.
So it's a little different
but you know it works out.
How long you guys been a band for?
Almost 10 years. XNL Oh good deal.
You got ain't you got a new
album or anything coming up?
The war thing has been
out for a little while.
We're going to be doing one more tour.
I'll draw specimen then working on new
records, so keep an eye out for that.
That's awesome. Always keep us
posted event next month. Thanks.
Thanks for that domestic
violence throttle. Thank you.
All Right, Nice Shit. That funny.
Go beat up your fucking girl. Palms.
They're idiots. Save it for the
bedroom. Save it for the bedroom.
Why did you punch her in the
bedroom? Oh God damn. Is that funny?
That's really good. We got one
more here from Peter from inflames.
Hey, what's up? It's
Cobra opiod Anthony show.
You know that cause you're
listen to this shit. Uh,
I'm with the bass player from
installation speed hours. Hey,
how would you set today man? Oh,
it's gonna be fine. Play. All right.
We need to start that again. So I
don't look like I ended up fucking,
how would you, oh man.
Like a retarded. Uh,
I get no rough assessment. So how do
you think your is going to go tonight?
You're looking forward. You on
the main stage. They over there.
I think it's going to
go great. I mean it's a,
we always put in 150% and you know,
it's a bit different from a sitting
down crowd but instead it's going to be
great.
So far the older shows has been mostly
so I'm pretty sure today will be as well.
So you guys don't like your vibe,
you come more mellow melodic that like
how you guys are? I think we're metal,
you know, it's hard to categorize us
as one basically. No. Okay. Alright.
So you're not like I had
made meats, you know, like,
like pitch movies and stuff.
You're like, I made me, uh,
I guess we could say that,
but it wouldn't be unfair probably to
just categorize it into one. You know,
I often, I don't like that we're metal
baton. Ah, that's cool man. That's cool.
How long you guys been planned?
A long time. And I also, uh,
I think it's like 12 years
something. The events,
like five years and have everybody in
the band. If you had to kill someone,
who would you kill myself. It's
really snow on the roadside and gets,
you know. No,
but I mean it wouldn't be fair to
the other silhouettes to choose one.
Oh God. That's just, no
one would go with it.
No one wants to come to
a fair to the others.
It wouldn't be fair to those of
eyes to choose one. I like this guy.
This guy can tell. You're like the
peacekeeper in the band, right?
You're like the mellow one.
Listen man, we're also doing,
now this is kind of a side thing, but
kind of doing this so there's benefit.
Somebody beat up a special needs
kid and like no work and a,
so we just want you to just say, you know,
just give a shout out to the kids so
they know not to beat up somebody with
like, you know, special needs, you
know, so just, you know, say like,
uh, you know, hey guys, you know,
it's not cool to beat up on somebody just
because they're different or whatever.
You know, just, you know, this
is like a quick, kind of like a,
like a soundbite and it's kind of
weird but throw a couple of, you know,
fox in there just cause I found the
kind of retarded, you know what I mean?
So you didn't like, you know,
I'm just playing there you
guys a spirit of replays.
She should've treated
everybody equally and uh,
don't beat anybody up or do something
bad to them. Just goes to a different,
everybody's the same way. Okay.
That's totally department vibe.
Just throw in special needs and
throw in like one or two fucks. Yeah,
the awkward, it's kind of
like I said, they were tired.
Same thing again or what? Yeah,
yeah. Hey, the spirit room,
flames a treat everybody
the same way. It'll be.
It's people still special needs and I'm
like that don't fucking go into and do
any bullshit than shooting
people up because of different
treat everybody at the
same time. That's beautiful.
And the kid's name is Russell.
Just give him a shout out to same thing.
Couple of blocks and a big metal fan.
So it means a lot to him. I scared.
Got beat up Russell from Newark. Only.
Fuck you're doing take care
of yourself, man. Season.
I do. That's beautiful man. Thanks
so much and good luck tonight.
Holy Shit. You are insane.
I love knowing the same breath.
Oh wish you could have seen the looks
on their face as they're trying to wrap
their fucking head around the
concert. I don't doubt it.
I love how in the same breath you're
saying this poor special needs kid. Yeah,
I'll listen as a fucking retard. And
they use this archaic term like retarded.
Oh Wow. Bill. That's
great. That was great.
Just to add special news and throw a
fucking couple and they just do it to say
hi to Russell. I'm noxious. Drown
the clown guy. What's this? Oh,
this guy was one of the funniest
acts that I've ever seen. He was a,
what's it called? Drown the clown.
You basically get all
the Dunkin stool dunking.
So some guy is sitting there in this
clown mass and he's just trashing these
peop. Half of them are fucking like
totally old jokes, but he says, Hey,
look at the white trash
people that you fucking lose.
And then even just said this
maniacal laugh like the clown Lou.
And then he'd just go get the end of it.
It was so fucking of Nazis.
He got some skinny kid.
He kept calling him a crack head and this
dude is literally walking behind what
you throw the balls like go,
come on. Dolphin Stole Mondo.
You wanted to kick his and kick his ass.
He would get these people so mad there'll
be like 20 of them and he'd get him so
mad. But by the time that
they actually like dumped him,
they would all start giving
the finger go fuck you.
And where you might need video
on this one. I don't know. I,
let's take a lesson. It's
obnoxious. Drown the clown guy.
Hey Buddy. You want a
milk crate to stand on?
What do you want to be
when you get old to fight?
So by body
[inaudible]
and then he's taunting him. I'm not sure.
I'm all pissed. Here's a
noxious drown the clown guy.
I guess a chick with no boobs
was in the area. Huh? Hey Mommy.
I know you love me. You
just don't know. We get
oh babies now. You bet
the DVD before here.
You don't want to. I can read
your shirt and your in dreams.
Why did before do this group?
Hey Buddy, it's going get
hot back then. A pound
[inaudible] a [inaudible]. I'm going
to get eaten the tables with face
move his eight three. Huh? I've
got one more drug fee on that.
Three d a v I can look at me.
You got to have the beautiful
blonde. Yeah. Why is he
[inaudible]
not this shit was just old jokes.
Just fucking the most
horrendous jokes and he said,
ah,
it sounds like Keith Robinson.
They laugh. I love this guy.
Love noxious asshole. You could have seen
these fucking people standing around.
How they all, there was
one dude, he had like a,
he was like completely bald on top and
he had a hat on and he took, he just,
I don't if he lost his hat, but his
face was like, like Puerto Rican Brown.
Right. And then his fucking
head was totally white.
[inaudible] head blows
up your fucking head.
Okay.
Raymond Adam and this fucking guy, he's
just losing. Yeah, look at my head.
And then they would try to throw the
balls even fucking harder and they're like
missing by like 20 feet
and every ball they throw.
Okay.
Oh, what an asshole. It was actually,
it was literally like a better
job than stand up in a way. Yeah.
You didn't have to just fucking sit
there and like goddamn parking lot.
You're right. You have to do an act.
You just fucking irritate people.
Time people. And it doesn't matter
how bad they try to heckle you back.
We got more from the obnoxious drown the
clown guy. What are you talking about?
[inaudible] I know you
ain't got a green color.
You got clean cod there was like Mexican.
I love that blend. Can we isolate
that? I want that on my machine.
He though words get that on
my machine. Hmm. Alright.
Another loser that he was making
fun of. What are you going to do?
You laid a lose out.
We were standing out there for like
six hours and you heard that laugh like
every three seconds. Oh.
People in the egg attain like
I'm gonna fucking kill it.
I put my head on the pillow and that's
all I hear. Is that guy laughing.
What are you doing? You're
bone head. Total ball. Huh?
Come on. You lose up. Give me
the second part of it. Done.
Yeah.
Oh, he wouldn't do the lab.
He could only do the laugh
when he was sitting there.
He probably doesn't even know what
you're talking about. The app part. No,
you look like with that red
shirt on like a fire truck
come off that boy on weight
and all you hold the logo.
Oh my God. I gotta do that all day. That
laughed out just off down the street.
Okay.
We've got to get that guy on the show.
How do we get ahold of that guy ass?
We need him on the show on the clown.
We need him at the next road show, man.
We're starting to put together
our first anniversary. A show.
Someone says it's Nice show
Colin Quinn getting worse.
You wouldn't have understood
the tonsil. Something Ironic.
I was doing a Gig in
Wildwood many years ago.
I was probably three years in the business
and some guy was heckling me and he
just rectally.
I talked to him after the show and he's
really a cool guy and it was one of
those guys, but one of those
fucking balls to really have. Yeah,
some of them like that
guy. Pretty good at.
It doesn't matter how old the
jokes are, not. Doesn't matter.
You got to see you say it with the right
attitude. It's going to work. You know,
pissed people off. It's
bad if he just like,
if you're completely uninhibited
and yeah, not going to shut up.
You'll win every time. Yeah. Very
funny stuff. Bill, you got to leave.
Are you staying? I can hang out
a little bit after 10. Alright,
cool.
[inaudible]
what am I talking about
here? Um, cheap two.
Can they show that fucking John Malcovich
talking to his phone and just having
the time of his life commercial one
more fucking time. What's more annoying?
That one or where that
weird family does the a,
the acapella version of
Ozzy Osborne's crazy train.
Would that random black kid in the back?
Like where did they get that kid? Like,
you know, was he an exchange student?
And he just seems like he's over all of
it and not enjoying hanging out with the
other white people as he fucking shakes
the ice in his it, his great drink,
you know,
and then they got to end that great song
with the parents singing like they're
on Broadway. Right.
Go ahead.
You know
anybody else with me on that? John fucking
Malcovich sitting there all you know
if that, if that commercial was 30
seconds longer, he'd have the phone like,
like blowing him. Tell me a joke.
Do I have anything coming
up tonight now? Oh,
lobster souffle or whatever.
Pretentious fucking foodie orders.
Was it pretentious bill?
Are you just not cultured?
And his order made you feel dumb.
All right, you got me on that one.
You got me on that one. Um,
I'm the only one who's creeped out that
there's a fucking robot in my phone.
Well, whatever it is, it's
that they try to make it human.
What did they do that just
make it sound like a robot.
Okay.
Hi. Can I have you massage parlor Garry?
[inaudible] just do it like that.
So I see it still keeps that like,
okay,
we keep that distance.
I don't need intimacy with this
thing that isn't fucking alive.
I don't need that 2001
space odyssey experience.
That's all I'm trying to say
here. People, oh, he's bill burr.
He's mad at phones. Get
out of his way. Everybody.
This guy has got something to say.
What's the deal with your mom?
Okay.
Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].